[Music]
[Music]
one of the commonalities one of the
patterns the spot really quickly if you
interview hundreds of world-class
performers and I just interviewed 130 or
so for my new book tribal mentors is the
fact that they have consistent morning
routines they have some type of recipe a
boot up sequence that they use to win
the day in some fashion and it ranges
from for instance mindfulness and that
could be mindfulness meditation where
you find say Evan Williams who is well
known for blogger Twitter also medium
who spends time every morning as I do
with some type of meditative practice
could be insight it could be a trans
dental meditation you could use an app
like headspace which i think is a great
place to start and it trains you it
allows you to practice becoming more
aware and less reactive so that you're
not thrown off by the unexpected
challenges and problems of the day and
that helps you to be much more
productive and much more centered you
can achieve that in other ways gratitude
is a common element so Tim O'Reilly who
is just an incredible entrepreneur
thinker writer and thought leader in
Silicon Valley goes for a run and will
take a photograph of a single flower on
his run every morning right and this
teaches you to pause to pause and to
assess how your se responding to things
so that is a really beautiful practice
that can be done with gratitude lists I
use something called the five minute
journal about Whitney Cummings
incredible stand-up comedian writer and
much more also has gratitude lists and
this is say naming three things that
you're grateful for each morning tony
robbins does this Brian Grazer
incredibly well known iconic TV and film
producer also does this I think he's had
a hundred and eighty Emmy nominations or
something like that and that achieves
very much the same thing of present
state awareness and looking for the
positive as opposed to fixating on the
negative and last but not least you have
Jocko willing retired Navy SEAL
commander who will lay out his clothes
his workout clothing the night before so
that there's no conscious decision
required were willpower or lack thereof
could intercede his clothing is ready
he's already set his to-do list for the
next day wakes up at he wakes up at 4:30
that's not quite when I wake up and
grabs the clothes boom directly to the
gym and he has a home gym where he does
his workout this is also very common
where people recognize these very busy
very driven people that if it's
inconvenient to work out they probably
won't do it
so Jocko has a home gym where barbell
plates squat rack three sets of rings at
different heights a kettlebell and
you're good to go that's all you need so
there's a few of the things that I've
seen repeatedly in different forms with
hundreds of top performers that they use
to win the morning so they can win the
day hey guys if you're enjoying the tips
and tactics and how-to on this channel
or in the podcast the Tim Ferriss show I
made this for you
try the mentors short advice from the
best in the world this is the book that
I wanted to read so I went out and I put
it together created a dream list 130 of
the best at what they do people who are
icons legends and asked them all the
same questions these are people in some
cases I wanted to reach out to my whole
life ranges from many many billionaires
cofounders of every company imaginable
elite athletes ranging from surfing to
tennis to powerlifting everything else
country stars actors directors and you
can spot the pattern so some of my
friends have said this is the easiest to
read most useful book that I've put
together yet
so check it out tribe of mentors dot-com
you can find sample chapters the whole
list of mentors everything tribe mentors
calm